[MUSIC PLAYING]
FEMALE SPEAKER: JackThreads
is a [INAUDIBLE] destination
for men's fashion.
I think everyone here is
unique in so many ways.
We have such a crazy,
hodgepodge of people here.
MALE SPEAKER: We
understand so much
about our guys'
needs, the demand
that they have for truly
personalized communication.
Almost 70% of the interactions
that we have with our audience
are mobile.
More than 50% of
our transactions
are driven through mobile.
We've leaned in really
hard to build best-in-class
mobile experiences,
where every day
you don't know what
you're going to find.
We want to feel
like the smallest
big company in the world.
LUIS: There's 1.2 billion
people in the world learning
a foreign language.
The majority of these people,
they're learning to get a job.
And they are of low
socioeconomic conditions.
My views on
education have always
been influenced by where I
come from which is Guatemala.
So Guatemala's a
very poor country.
I wanted to come up
with a way to teach
languages that
was entirely free.
Today, Duolingo is
the most popular way
to languages in the world.
We have 30 million students.
There are more people learning
a language on Duolingo
than in the entire US
public school system.
85% of the people use
it through an app.
Over the next 20
years, education
is going to fundamentally shift.
Smartphones are going to
allow us to bring education
to the people who don't
have access to it.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
We had seen Andres
a couple times during our PE
period, studying the track.
And we didn't realize it
took so much work to actually
get to near the school.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
They have to live
through darkness every day.
No one can really feel it and
they take seeing for granted.
FEMALE SPEAKER: We
were like, why not
create something that will
actually make a difference?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Hello
Navi will use GPS
and a location
sensor so that way
you can have a specific point
for each of his classes.
HELLO NAVI: Where
do you want to go?
FEMALE SPEAKER: The coding, it
took weeks just to get it down.
FEMALE SPEAKER: If you mess
up one little tiny thing,
it can mess up the whole app.
FEMALE SPEAKER: We made a
difference not just to him,
but to the many others who
will eventually use this app.
ANDRES: They care about me.
That's why they made
this app happen.
I never got to hear the
word, "inspiration,"
in my whole entire life.
It made me proud.